what are the things that we can do to
improve our brain performance rest which
is sleep also downtime nutrition is
super important so the brain is any
proportion of your body weight but it
uses up to 30 percent of the breakdown
products of what you eat so when you're
asleep your brain is heating up 20 of
what you ate that day when you're at
work and focused on something it's using
up about a quarter of what you eat and
when you're stressed it's using up to 30
and so obviously people think what
should I eat if I want to be healthy
generally or I want to lose weight or I
want to build muscle mass but aren't
thinking enough about what should I be
eating so I can make the best decisions
today what should I be eating so I can
solve complex problems considering this
organ is so energy hungry and it's so
important in terms of everything else
that happens in your body I feel like we
need to flip that narrative so that it's
starting with what things can I do today
that are going to be the best for my
brain